today former New York gubernatorial
candidate Lee zeldon here in studio nice
to see you sir good to see you we're
Congressman you ran for governor you
failed at that however you ran a really
good campaign and drove a lot of these
issues into the conversation question
for you
um here's here's uh yeah New York Post
got it Bravo to Eric Adams for his
verbal volleys at the border but what
will he actually do in truth I think
this is the biggest statement he has
made as mayor of New York what do you
think I agree instead of this red State
versus Blue State red City versus Blue
City battle that was going on the
reality was that even if all of the
Democrats and Republicans who were
battling were totally on the same page
for fixing this you're not going to
actually resolve this until the federal
government in the Biden Administration
steps up and does what they need to do
to secure Southern borders so it's
appropriate and the city mayor is right
by saying that it's on the federal
government first and foremost to resolve
this okay some of this ran yesterday I
want to play it again on Sunday at the
border here is Eric Adams New York's
mayor
this is a national problem we must have
real immigration reform and we must
immediately have a short-term fix of
making sure that the cost of this does
not fall on our local cities case the
case he's making is that New York City
is spending millions and millions of
dollars but New York has said we're a
sanctuary City if you want to come here
you're welcome so what now well and
that's a problem New York City operating
as a sanctuary City New York State
operating as a sanctuary State having
these incentives and rewards is sending
a message to people who aren't yet in
the country that if they can get here
they can make their way all the way up
to New York that this is the environment
that's waiting for them it's encouraging
people to just go through their own
process of coming into the country even
if it's illegally so I do believe it
needs to get changed now as far as the
drain on resources we see with shelters
with hotels with schools with medical
facilities the costs for taxpayers for
people who are here hard-working
struggling to make ends meet and are in
New York legally it ends up being
unbearable and this trajectory right now
is unsustainable I think the city can do
its part and the state can do its part
by reversing these sanctuaries okay so
he's had a lot of tough language for the
feds he had a lot of language for FEMA
did he say President Biden by name
that's a problem and the thing is Eric
Adams which you know credit to him for
saying that it's important for the
federal government to take action
leadership here but when he talks about
immigration reform I don't think he's
talking about finishing construction of
the border wall ending Catch and Release
enforcing the remain in Mexico policy
stop incentivizing rewarding the illegal
entry and also by the way we should be
better supporting our Customs and Border
Patrol agents so just using the term we
need immigration reform from the federal
government doesn't necessarily mean that
this is coming with the specifics that
will actually solve it we've been there
for two years some other media Outlets
have been there for the past month
but the bus has worked because it drew
attention to the issue the flight out of
Florida to Martha's Vineyard Drew
attention to the issue would you agree
with that 100 absolutely and it ended up
adding the pressure would mayor Adams be
at the southern border putting pressure
on the federal government to act if not
for the way that New York City has been
forced to bear this brunt now I'm not
advocating for you know buses and
flights to be coming to to New York City
but the fact is to your question
absolutely when when this was not just a
Florida issue a Florida Channel I'm
sorry a Texas issue a Texas Challenge
and you had some of these blue City Blue
State leadership forced to try to figure
out what to do ended up changing the
conversation and we see media also in
places like New York City and I'm
joining what as you pointed out fox has
been on this for years uh we have
another quick story here and that is
about crime in America this is a big
part of your campaign there was a study
out of California that looked at 16
major American cities here's what they
found
Asian hate crimes reported to police in
16 of America's largest cities and
counties Rose 164 percent in the first
quarter of 2021 in comparison first
quarter previous year 2020. what's that
tell you they are very fed up with the
Democratic party foot crime is a top
issue for them we won in our
gubernatorial race Chinatown and
Manhattan flushing in Queens Sunset Park
in Brooklyn we won the Asian American
vote even though they are predominantly
Democrat why because people in their own
Community push in front of an oncoming
subway car and killed stay up to death
in their apartment in lower Manhattan
beaten to death on the street with a
hammer we're not just talking about an
assault we're talking about people who
are actually losing their life and the
Asian American community in New York
City felt like an attack on one of them
was an attack on all of them and they
wanted to do something about it and they
felt like the Democratic party wasn't
serious enough about fighting crime we
shall see whether or not that Trend
continues very interesting nice to see
you again good to see you I see you
recovered yes sir Lee zeldon thanks here
in New York I'm Steve juicy I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis